you should only wear a band T-shirt If
you know all of their songs you should
only
wear agree no but what if the T-shirt
like what does it matter if you don't
well like if I had a band with Like
Girls Allowed no I do know most yeah
exactly but like if it's a cool t-shirt
are you're not just going to wear it
anyway with a with a band I wouldn't I
have loads of t-shirts where you're like
that like there's a there's a Faith No
More t-shirt that I wear it's red and
has a dog on it I don't know their music
do you know any songs not a single song
oh that is a strong disagree do you know
a lot of people going oh Faith No More I
lie I'm like yeah I I love
them yeah yeah yeah yeah these are good
questions oh thank you